now your work in advertising has often
been portrayed as
is it and couldn't you easily change the
image it's interesting question that to
what extent working in advertising and
marketing is promoted as being evil the
fact is that advertising itself is
neither good nor evil its individual
advertisements and actions that can be
good or bad it also I think reflects an
interesting bias which is that we tend
to regard the production of tangible
goods as being inherently virtuous even
when to be honest those goods may be
actually fairly useless more
inefficiently produced or produced at
some external cost whereas we tend to
regard the creation of intangible value
or perceived value as somehow Felli
dubious and this is based on the
assumption that everything has an
intrinsic value and marketing or other
activities simply tamper with that
intrinsic value by adding some magic
dust of some kind or another I think
there's another way of looking at it
which say that actually there's no
sensible distinction to be made as the
Austrian school of economist would say
between the value in a restaurant rate
by cooking the food and the value you
create by sweeping the floor one creates
the food itself the other creates the
context and the environment in which you
can enjoy the food and since I genuinely
believe that value is subjective and is
the product of all kinds of biases and
influences including the frame we
attached to things I don't think there's
anything inherently wrong with adding
perceptual value to things so whereas
you can say yes undoubtedly you know we
have been the cause of some possibly
some pointless or unhealthy consumerism
I think it's equally true to say that if
you want this world which people claim
they aspire to in which actually you
know you can be prouder of owning less
rather than more what that actually
requires this perception shift
in terms of economic value on obviously
there are things where there's a greater
degree of necessity but I think if you
look at if you look at most forms of
value I think then you can pick things
apart and realize that actually what we
think of as having an objective value
actually has a value because of some
sort of frame we place it on now if you
take fashion goods luxury goods for
example patently they have a symbolic or
sine value not just a use value and that
partly resides free largely resides
psychologically now I would argue that
the biggest problems caused in in
perceptual value are not in those areas
of people get buy shampoo or bear or
whatever it may be we're actually I
think consumers choose fairly well and
where the effects after all are making a
bad choice are relatively small and
where thanks actually is into the
existence of major brands the level of
trust in marketplaces is very high it is
worth remembering by the way and I want
to qualify this that having a brand
reputation is a double-edged sword we
tend to see it as an unfair advantage in
the marketplace which it is so long as
you live up to that reputation with your
behavior but it's equally true to say
that people with a reputation are much
more vulnerable to reputation or threat
if their behavior fails to live up to
their promise and so to some extent if
you look at it in a game theoretic way
actually what a brand is is something of
value to the producer which is held
hostage by the consumer to be abused or
damaged in in times or moments when the
producer doesn't live up to his word so
there is that interesting thing and that
brand reputation is some extent we won't
forget it's actually used by consumers
to keep producers honest so are you
saying the consumer has as much power do
sir well if you most purchases involve a
high degree of uncertainty how do you
know the person is simply selling you a
dodgy television in all
to make a quick buck and consumers seem
to look for as I do I'm not just
consumers I'm everybody looks for
indications that this isn't the case why
on earth should I depend on that person
or trust them and actually a reputation
is one thing we can use because it's
fragile because a reputation actually
even though built over many years can be
destroyed very very quickly is one of
the things we look for as a sign that
the seller has something to lose by
ripping us off and so you know you can
almost look at hostage situations as
analogous to this how can i check what
can I do to hurt the man if he doesn't
deliver the goods as promised and a
reputation is arguably the least violent
way in which you can actually do damage
to someone who's lets you down and so
they're all sorts of sort of i think i
think as yet and performed at work into
reputational game theory and how brands
actually some extent keep markets honest
which is which is yet to be done but
then there's this other question as I
said about behavior change and
attitudinal change I was saying the
biggest problems aren't really where we
buy shampoo or where we were beer when
you get a collective delusion about
something for example if you look at the
property market there was very peculiar
thing that went on which wasn't
perpetrated by the advertising industry
or by marketing or indeed wasn't even
perpetrated deliberately with any
necessary suspicion of self-interest it
was just a universal belief that a rise
in property prices was good news and on
the news at ten or whatever you'd have a
good news story of property prices have
gone up and it was considered terrible
news if property prices has gone down
the whole of a second you know property
isn't just an investment vehicle it's a
form of consumption young people have
much less of it than old people do why
are you favoring the interests of
property owners over non property owners
in your coverage and that was
interesting because in a sense we were
far less people in general with far less
suspicious of what was going on there
precisely because it didn't have any
naked self-interest behind it when
people see an advertisement they accept
the fact that it is an adverse
and that they understand the job it's
trying to do so actually what you might
call unintentional propaganda is far by
far the more dangerous thing now nobody
nobody announces a good news story on
the news when petrol prices go up nobody
says great news for those of you who've
got half a tank full of petrol the price
of petrol hence the value of your car is
going up tomorrow that would be
considered as an absurd thing to do and
yet property was treated as this
entirely separate category for a period
of about 20 years as if the only thing
it could do was go up and that was an
entirely a desirable result with no
deleterious consequences for anybody
else that's the thing you've really got
to be frightened off in terms of
psychological at what you might call
collective delusion